David de Faria is a lawyer and former
and former foreign policy advisor to the
Obama campaign and he joins the same old
enough to remember when it was the party
of peace now the party of mandatory war
so I'm just wondering why shouldn't we
have a debate about article 5 in NATO
which obligates the United States and
all members of NATO to defend the
interests of other states so why would
should we be on the hook for this for
the territorial integrity of Estonia and
Latvia seriously there's nothing wrong
with having a debate we're gonna have
one right now I hope it'll be
educational it's important to note that
NATO has been successful in the past as
the eteri and Intelligence Sharing
Alliance and also as an alliance of
like-minded countries you admitted that
in your opening that NATO was successful
in defeating I would say Soviet Union
right yes
now NATO is still needed history repeats
itself Putin's Russia is not the same as
the Soviet Union but it's trying to do
some of the same things it's trying to
stamp out rule of law it doesn't believe
in freedom it doesn't believe in free
markets it's trying to spread a vision
of a kleptocracy that will enrich Putin
and enrich the other oligarchs that's
what I've been Russia and they're trying
to spread it to the rest that's right I
mean but how is that different from
China only in that it's less effective
so I don't think that Russia has taken
over Africa or Latin America yet or the
Caribbean China has what but it's
totally aligned it's totally fine to get
rich from sucking up the Chinese
oligarchs our whole ruling class does
but it's wrong not to defend Latvia
against Putin because why no you're
right I mean oh yeah I'm Radio NATO is
also an alliance that's aligned against
China in many ways as well so it's it's
what's impairing Russia to China doesn't
somehow make what what you're describing
you're trying to explain why it's you
know America's vital interest to start a
nuclear war to defend wow I did not say
that that's what we'd be obligated it's
in America's vital interests to defend
other countries around the world that
are trying to become democracies that
are trying to promote freedom that are
trying to pro individual rights they're
trying to protect human rights and most
importantly protect rule of law that's
what laughs er the other Baltic states
that have joined NATO support we are
doing and we should encourage that we
should
I'm extending that security umbrella to
them which is what do this show in other
words our kids get to die for Latvia
because it somehow protects the rule of
law for them to do that and I'm just
asking does the average American
understand that we're on the hook for
this I think that's a real question
which is trying to be ignored they're
trying to shut down the conversation you
have to look at history if Latvia and
the other Baltic states fall to an
aggressive Russia ultimately other
countries in in the Europe and
ultimately it will come back to us
anyway just like they were to see these
same arguments people made against not
doing in favor of not doing anything
against Germany and the Nazis a minute
what's the exact same argument okay it's
what the whole impacts are you actually
making that argue you are the Nazis
don't exist in neither business Soviet
Union I'm making an argument rooted in
2019 which is where we are right now and
I'm interested very interested since you
brought it up in what Western European
countries do you think are at threat of
being invaded by Russia well certainly
the the countries that have recently
joined NATO the Baltic States are a
threat that's why you brought them up
okay Ukraine Ukraine is not part of NATO
yet right but the reason of the Union
when I their music like yeah 20 minutes
yeah but it wanted to be free but and
now it is free lots of people want to be
free understand it deserves me but in
Western Europe what countries the core
countries Western Europe nativist Poland
is not a core country in Western Europe
now get bringing it back to and I okay
so you're you're willing to cede all of
Eastern Europe just even in countries
like : that's allies that are part of
NATO and say we could only protect
Western Europe I'm I'm at because
Eastern Europe goes then Western Europe
is threatened so you don't think there's
a we're almost done you think there's a
plausible threat within our lifetimes of
say the UK Germany beldam Liechtenstein
Switzerland Spain Portugal being invaded
by Russia I'm not saying that but what
you were saying all of the other
countries in Eastern Europe including
the ones that have joined NATO fell then
of course the next frontier for Russia
expansionism would be Western Europe so
first they can't last
yeah not obvious wrong me but keep
trying
great see David thank you thank you